bonjour ça vous dirait de faire de la
musique ça commence déjà bien
c'est une question que je me pose
souvent autour de moi en fait si je vous
invite un jour à boire un verre ou à
manger quelque chose c'est moins il ya
de bonnes chances pour qu à un moment ou
un autre je vous propose de faire de la
musique
malheureusement on répond souvent je ne
suis pas musicien et ça ça me je trouve
ça vraiment triste parce que la musique
d'une pincée quelque chose de très
naturel à la base c'est le chant le
rythme les percussions la danse des
choses qui n'ont pas attendu qu'on
fabrique des instruments qu'on crée des
musicales pour exister et c'est quelque
chose qui vous appartient quelque chose
que vous pouvez non importe qui peut
faire du moment que ça fait des oreilles
pour entendre la musique autour de vous
vous avez une bouche pour recréer ce que
vous entendez et que vous avez des mains
et des bras à la limite pour pour
essayer d'accompagner rythmiquement ce
que ce que vous entendez vous pouvez
faire de la musique est d'ailleurs dans
mon travail musical c'est très souvent
quand je compose un nouveau morceau d'en
faire une version très naturel à partir
uniquement de partir uniquement de son
de percussions que je crée sans
instrument juste sur mon corps ou sur le
sol et de voix est peut-être un tout
petit instrument à la rigueur et
j'essaye de rester très proche de 2,7
naturalité de la musique et je fais des
choses comme ceux ci par exemple
j'enregistre se sont j'enregistre
j'enregistre ce genre de son et puis au
final j'ai créé un morceau j'ai créé une
base de morceaux sur laquelle je pouvoir
tester des mélodies avant même d'avoir
commencé à faire des arrangements pour
d'autres instruments
m
peut-être que vous avez envie de faire
de la musique avec des instruments
d'apprendre de la théorie musicale des
choses qui ne peuvent pas se
transmettent rien qu en les répétant
vous avez besoin de rencontrer des gens
d'apprendre quelque chose demain là
aussi vous n'avez jamais été aussi
autonome qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pour
faire de la musique pour faire beaucoup
d'autres choses
tout ce qui vous suffit d'avoir c'est la
curiosité et à partir du moment où vous
êtes curieux de quelque chose il ya de
bonnes chances pour que vous le soyez
déjà potentiellement vous êtes tous déjà
potentiellement musiciens alors vous
êtes peut-être me dire que être
potentiellement musiciens ça fait pas
grand chose pour vous et ce n'est pas en
jouant potentiellement de la guitare à
la lumière d'une bougie que vous allez
emballer les filles mais c'est déjà très
important parce que ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas et je n'ai que 37 ans mais
c'est déjà assez pour avoir vécu quinze
ans avant internet et vingt ans après
internet et d'avoir vu une différence
énorme
et quand je repense à la façon par
laquelle je suis arrivé à la musique je
me souviens que mes premiers le premier
intérêt musicaux était la musique de
dessins animés
quand vous entendez ceux ci ont constaté
qu'il ya une constante là dedans à
l'époque je ne m'en rendais pas encore
compte mais la constante que j'ai
découvert plus tard ce sont les sons
synthétiques
d'ailleurs les au delà des génériques de
dessins animés les sont de manière
générale dans les dessins animés tout ce
qui était bruitages effets sonores
étaient aussi réalisé des synthétiseurs
comme celui ci les années 70 et vous
reconnaissez le type de sons vous
entendiez dans les séries sans suite son
aile et dessins animés mais à l'époque
je n'ai pas encore fait le lien
alors j'ai continué à écouter de la
musique et même en même en écoutant des
premières les premières chansons mes
premiers souvenirs de chansons qui m'ont
marqué
elle avait tout quelque part tourner
tout autour des synthétiseurs et
progressivement mon oreille commençait à
déceler quelque chose de constant mais
je ne savais pas encore concrètement ce
que c'était et c'est seulement en allant
chez des amis de mes parents à un jour
et en leur disant que j'adorais cette
musique de générique
dumont dit en fait ce sont les eaux sont
des synthétiseurs et on vient justement
d'acheter un nouvel album de jean michel
jarre
on en était en 1986 j'avais 9 ans et ils
l'ont faire c'était mon premier album
ils m'ont dit ça c'est de la musique
composer avec des synthétiseurs si tu
aimes bien cette musique c'est que tu
aimes bien les synthétiseurs pour partir
de ce moment c'était pour moi j'avais
neuf ans que je voulais faire dans la
vie c'est faire du synthétiseur
on disait pas que j'allais faire de la
musique j'allais faire quoi que ce soit
je disais je veux faire du synthétiseur
j'aimerais vous pouvoir vous dire que
c'est comme ça que ma carrière 2010 a
commencé mais malheureusement c'est pas
le cas parce que à l'époque je n'avais
aucun pompon dans ma vie entre mon
entourage entre ce que je connaissais et
les gens qui détenait ce savoir qui
aurait pu me guider dans la découverte
des synthétiseurs et même si j'ai
commencé la guitare
quelques années plus tard et que je fais
c'est continuer dans la musique pour
finalement apprendre à utiliser des
synthétiseurs bien plus tard sur le
moment même je suis resté sur une
frustration et cette frustration c'est
quelque chose qui a complètement
disparue aujourd'hui ou en tout cas qui
qui dresse pas pour les mêmes raisons et
je vais me présenter quelque chose de
beaucoup plus récent dans mon travail
pour vous montrer comme aujourd'hui on
n'est plus du tout dans le même monde
il ya quelques années j'ai eu envie de
me créer un instrument alors je ne suis
pas un inventeur mais c'est pas pour ça
que ça m'a arrêté j'ai eu l'idée pour un
de mes groupes de musique électronique
de créer un instrument qui se
contrôlerait avec les mains ça m'a tout
de suite fait penser au thérémine au
thérémine c'est un des premiers
instruments de musique électronique qui
a été créée en 1920 par les enterrer
mines et c'est un instrument qui se
contrôlent justement avec les mains ces
composés d'un générateur qui produit un
son continu et deux antennes dont on
approche les mains pour faire monter la
hauteur de la nôtre où le volume et
je ne savais pas du tout comment
fonctionnent les intérêts mine mais j'ai
cherché un petit peu sur internet et
j'ai tout de suite trouvé quantité
d'informations sur le sujet 20 gens qui
avaient construit eux-mêmes leur propre
terminent parfois avec des simplement
des bouts de ficelle quels composants
électroniques qui listait entièrement
avec même les liens sur les magasins
pour les acheter en ligne les schémas
les des exemples de ce qu'il fallait
faire et ne pas faire et j'avais tout ce
qu'il fallait pour me créer un theremin
mais je me suis dit quitte à me faire
mon propre instrument autant faire
quelque chose qui soit plus générale
parce que je savais que je voulais
interagir avec du son et peut-être même
autre chose de la lumière de la vidéo je
voulais un intérêt direct ou ça avec des
gestes
je ne voulais pas me cantonner à un seul
son un seul type d'utilisation alors
j'ai décidé de faire ce qu'on appelle un
contrôleur midi un contrôleur midi
c'est un ce n'est pas un instrument qui
génère du son en soi mais c'est quelque
chose qui permet de contrôler un
ordinateur ou un synthétiseur comme ceux
ci par exemple c'est un contrôleur midi
ça ne génère pas de sons mais ça me
permet de contrôler un simple heures qui
tourne sur mon ordinateur j'ai donc
voulu générer un contrôleur midi
j'ai cherché un petit peu sur internet
concrètement comment ça allait se faire
même si je ne suis pas électronicien je
me suis dit à l'heure actuelle ça ne
doit pas être très compliqué et j'ai mes
raisons j'ai tout de suite trouvé des
capteurs de proximité qui sont ces
appareils 6 qui allait me permettre de
capter mais mouvement allait transformer
en un signal électrique c'est tout y
trouver des petits circuits déjà tout
fait qui transforme et signal on me dit
que j'allais pouvoir connecter à un
ordinateur et sans avoir à besoin à les
souder moi même et à me tracasser du
design de ce composant à ne pas
réinventer la roue et j'ai aussi trouvé
très facilement un petit synthétiseur
gratuit d'ailleurs qui reproduisent le
son intérim in monte les mines étaient
fonctionnels
je les utilisais en concert et
l'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là mais
une idée rebondissant sur une autre ma
soeur qui est plasticienne
bon je vous passe le design de ce
magnifique appareil parce que je pense
que ça se passe de mots ma soeur qui est
plasticienne m'a demandé si je voulais
participer à une exposition avec elle
est donnée de l'interactivité de ses
oeuvres
alors vu que je vais travailler avec des
capteurs de proximité je lui dis ben oui
j'imagine très bien un système où je
pourrai approcher 20 de tests culture à
un endroit ou un autre et déclencher des
vidéos selon l'endroit où je
m'approchais des vidéos qui expliquerait
comment cette telle ou telle partie de
l'oeuvre a été a été réalisé et mais
pour ça j'avais besoin d'un élément
supplémentaire
j'avais besoin de quelque chose qui trie
l'organisation qui détecte calcul pardon
avec l'ensemble des capteurs autour de
l'oeuvre qui calcule l'endroit exact que
l'on pointé du doigt et la vidéo
annoncée pour ça j'ai pensé à quelque
chose que je connaissais très vaguement
juste de nom un arduino mais il n'avait
jamais eu l'occasion d'utiliser je ne
connais pas la ruine au mais je suis sûr
que tu es création et internet doit
savoir comment ça fonctionne donc j'en
ai acheté un sac coûte quelques dizaines
de dollars
j'ai suivi quelques projets qui
ressemblait vaguement ont bien et en
deux temps trois mouvements
l'installation était prête tout
fonctionnait et j'avais appris quelque
chose de nouveau et ça m'a permis
justement d'aller un peu plus loin dans
la réflexion sur mon instrument c'est
vrai que je voulais qu'il soit général
et qu'ils ne fassent pas que quand son
theremin mais dans la pratique je
l'avais utilisé en concert que pour ça
et je me suis dit dans les cas où tout
ce que je veux faire c'est un petit sons
de synthétiseurs c'est dommage
d'utiliser un ordinateur juste pour ça
alors peut-être que dans un arduino je
pourrais programme est un synthétiseur
jeu pourrait programmer un petit
theremin j'ai essayé ça n'a pas marché
mais ça m'a quand même lancé sur l'idée
que je pouvais aussi créer cette partie
là de la machine moi même que je pouvais
créer le son alors j'ai continué à
chercher nous y tomber là dessus c'est
une application qui venait juste de
sortir créé par un artiste new yorkais
qui permet de charger des synthétiseurs
écrit dans un langage qu'on appelle pure
data sur une tablette ou sur un
smartphone
alors je ne connaissais pas pure data
laissez moi j'avais beaucoup de choses
que je ne connaissais pas mais final
c'est une belle histoire vous allez voir
je ne connaissais pas pure data mais je
me suis vite renseigner et ce n'était
pas si compliqué que ça en tout cas avec
mon background j'avais peut-être
certaines facilités et g en un jour ou
deux j'ai créé j'ai appris le langage et
créer moi-même mon application qui est
celle qui tourne à présent surmonté les
mines j'ai créé aussi l'interface
graphique avec les outils mis à
disposition par le concepteur de cette
application
et si la technique veut bien me suivre
je pourrais même vous faire écouter à
quoi ça ressemble
bah voila je pourrais jouer le très
longtemps avec mais je pense que mon
timing ne me le permettrais pas à partir
de maintenant on oblige edmond machine
est indépendante et j'écris toutes les
parties de la partie qui capte les
mouvements à la partie qui me qui génère
le son et tout cela il ya pas si
longtemps ça ne serait pas ça m'aurait
paru impossible quand je compare ces
deux expériences extrêmes à 30 ans
d'interviews ça me rend à 30 ans
d'intervalle je me rends compte que ce
n'était pas juste améliorer ça n'a rien
à voir
et aujourd'hui ça me chagrine et ça ça
m'énerve ou même quand j'entends qu'on a
encore cette impression quand on ne
connaît pas déjà un domaine où qu'on
n'est pas content grandit pas dedans
qu'on n'a pas fait des études dedans on
peut on ne peut même pas y accéder et
c'est pour ça que je suis convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui les phrases telles que je
ne ne suis pas musicien je ne connais
pas la ruine au je ne connais pas si je
ne connais pas ceux là où je ne suis pas
luthier oui parce que j'ai découvert
l'année dernière 1 un instrument qui m'a
fasciné jeu je vais probablement essayer
d'en faire un moi-même mais c'est une
autre histoire
toutes ces choses que dont on se dit
qu'on ne peut pas les faire simplement
parce que ce n'est pas notre domaine
c'est une histoire de fou de cette poule
qui se cache la dernière
et puis de toute façon si les deux
exemples dont je vous ai parlé pour
quelque chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
seule chose qui peut peut-être définir
les limites dans lesquelles on peut
évoluer dans lesquels on peut apprendre
c'est la curiosité et ça tombe bien je
suis très curieux
merci